welcome to folding ideas season 3
episode 1.1 this is a mini so now you
may be asking what's a mini Soudan
what's the point to the point 1 well the
point 1 is a mini soda and a mini soda
it's just a short little episode they'll
be coming along as addendums Corrections
ideas that I want to talk about but
can't quite fill an entire 15 minutes
worth of regular episode so for this
mini episode on the subject of books
we're going to be talking about John
dies at the end
specifically I want to talk about genre
mixing now many people when I tell them
I've been reading a great book it's
called John dies at the end it's a
horror comedy they look at me like a
little bit crazy like how do you have
horror and how do you have comedy at the
same time and you know what I say to
them I say that is a perfectly valid
question how do you have comedy and
horror at the same time so how do you
manage to get horror in there with the
comedy David Wong manages to blend the
comedy and horror genres by keeping the
stakes real he does it in a very subtle
and effective way by keeping the stakes
high the stakes of the stakes the stakes
are kept the the comedy side of things
is fairly straightforward the book is
humorously written jokes are funny like
there's this moment in the book where
John and Dave learn is coming to then
they get into an argument over whether
and ultimately they just evolved into a
classic even though the characters are
thrown into ludicrous circumstances the
stakes the threat that the characters
are faced with remains real within the
context of the novel even though they're
fighting giant monstrosity is made
entirely out of frozen meat the story
still communicates well the idea that
they are under very real threat of
physical bodily harm and that they might
not be coming out of these circumstances
beyond that a lot of the horror stems
from a cosmological or existential
horror similar to HP Lovecraft the idea
that the main characters are coming to
the realization that no matter how witty
or funny or involve their lives maybe
they are just insignificant bugs in the
face of the ultimate reality of time and
space much of the comedy comes directly
from the characters as they crack wise
trying to cope with the horrors that
they're faced with and the new
understanding of the universe that they
gain as reality unfolds around them what
else should I say about it hmm
so did he stick some comedy into some
horror or some horror into a comedy
doesn't really matter as many
Frankenstein and Dracula films have
shown us horror doesn't come from the
monsters themselves it comes from the
threat so that's it because the horror
stems from danger by keeping that
element of danger intact the horror is
maintained even through the comedy and
that's it just a tiny little tidbit
thanks for watching
help
yeah yeah that's beard
that's a real beer